[Music] there are hundreds of football teams in
the land but only one team wins the Super Bowl
there are hundreds of baseball teams
but only one team wins the World Series
there are dozens of automobiles but only
one that's number one throughout the world
Chevrolet the team that engineers Chevrolet
is number one the cars and trucks they design
have greater public acceptance than any
others in the world the team that builds
Chevrolet is number one every year they build
more cars and trucks than anybody else anywhere
the team that sells Chevrolet's is also number
one for every year they sell more manufactured
goods and services than any other sales team
in existence number one team think if you will
what it means to be number one and then think
what it took to become number one years back
in 1911 when that very first Chevrolet was put
together in the shorty garage in Detroit Buick
was already a household word Oldsmobile was
building five thousand cars a year while Ford
was already building the greatest automobile
plant in the world at Highland Park Michigan
how could anyone dream that this car place 1913
Chevrolet the Cinderella of the industry could
dare to challenge Ford Ford alone controls
50% of the market he's building a quarter of
a million cars a year everywhere you look there
our forts challenge this challenge Ford take on
the leader of the industry lock horns from the
undisputed master of the more ridiculous absurd
impossible so say the experts but the men who
build the first Chevrolet know they are building
more than a corner they are forging a team a team
comprised of the men who designed Chevrolet build
Chevrolet and sell chevrolet this team as much
as the car itself would challenge the industry
slowly determinedly the chevrolet team begins
its bid for leadership in 1913 they build and
sell 3,000 cars Ford sells four hundred thousand
1917 fighting desperately the Chevrolet team Rams
it sales up to a record-breaking 126 thousand
but Ford goes over the 1/2 million mark 1925
with sales continuing to zoom upwards Chevrolet
production reaches a record high of 500,000 units
in a single year but Ford Ford goes over
the million mark 1926 Chevrolet organizes
the first sales conference in the industry
the first sales training program the first
sales Achievement Awards the first cooperative
advertising campaign a new spirit in flames the
Chevrolet team sales begin to soar eight million
dollars is pumped into new facilities to expand
Chevrolet production to a million units a
year [Music] 1927 the impossible happens
the thing the experts said could never occurred
the dark horse that came from nowhere smashes home
to victory the leader the champion the master
of them all Chevrolet is now the undisputed
number one team 1928 for the second year in a
row Chevrolet hangs up a victory over Fort 1930
impression stalks the land sales fall but while
others are wailing about conditions Chevrolet's
number one team goes to work with more vigor
and drive than ever before to prove to the
world that when things are toughest and they
can be even more determined for the 3rd 4th 5th
and 6th years Chevrolet wars into the finish line
meeting everyone else in the industry including 4